with march madness in full swing all
kinds of people have been
out and about today madison kimbrough
joins us live in the strip tonight with
more details
madison yes many people visiting vegas
calling it an escape as we're in the
second day of the ncaa tournament
and people are feeling the energy take a
look
i didn't expect it to be this packed but
yeah it is a lot of people
the view in our city looks a bit
different this weekend
streets are buzzing hotels and casinos
busier than usual
whether that's because of our increased
capacity of 50 percent
or because people are feeling more
comfortable after getting vaccinated
one thing is for sure we haven't seen a
weekend in the strip corridor like this
in a long time
it just seems like there's a lot more to
do here a lot more people out a lot more
excitement
been working from home for the last year
and just really wanted to get out the
house so i drove up here
to walk around do some shopping a little
gambling
today is also day two of march madness
over at west gate it's the busiest
they've seen since last june
many people expressing their joy that
the tournament has returned to the
westgate super book
once again energy is unbelievable i've
talked to a couple of our
loyal customers from other parts of the
country and they
were just heartbroken last year when we
didn't host this event
it was canceled and obviously that had a
huge impact on all these basketball fans
sports fans as for making sure everyone
complies with the safety protocols
the superbook decided to limit their
capacity to even lower than 50 percent
just to play it safe with their full
capacity being at 2200 people
this past week they stopped doing their
temperature checks but masks are still
required
and people will be told to space out if
they are not doing so
cornygay says the first weekend is
typically when they see the biggest
turnout
march madness is a very unique event
that is actually more popular at the
beginning of
it than the end of it so you'll see the
crowds kind of dwindle as the tournament
goes along
i mean we'll still have a nice crowd for
the final four but it's all
about this first weekend
and as for new spots opening up virgin
hotels opens
this thursday and the link will open up
back to seven days a week starting on
monday reporting live on the las vegas
strip madison kimbrough 8 news now